good news everybody this video is
sponsored by bright sellers who provide
one of the greatest services of any
sponsor on this channel they send wine
directly to your door all you have to do
is remember to put your pants on before
going outside to get it easy simple
beautiful so look if you're like me you
probably like discovering and drinking
wine it's brilliant and that's precisely
what brightsellers does so well for you
they scour the globe looking for hidden
gems from all those small little
vineyards around the place and bright
sellers maximizes the chances that
you're going to love the wine they send
you by providing you with a super short
seven question quiz about what you like
there's no snobbery it's all super
accessible and then they show you a list
of wines from around the world that
you're most likely to enjoy based on
your response is amazing when you're
done bright sellers send you your wine
with guarantee that you'll like it and
if you don't they'll ship you another
bottle with your next delivery so you
really can't lose what else where you
can choose a much they send and of
course it's delivered to you wherever
you want it to go making everything
super easy each box is recyclable low
footprint and features these wine
education cards you can learn a bit
about what you're drinking which is a
nice bonus isn't it also they
occasionally have flash sales where for
example let's say they've got a bunch of
wine where the labels are damaged they
will be able to sell that to you for a
ridiculously low price it's awesome
right now bright settlers is giving you
guys 50 off your first six bottle box
that's 55
for six bottles of wine which is an
amazing deal there's a link in the
description below go get started and now
today's video
in the pantheon of american poetry
there's one name that looms above all
others walt whitman was larger than life
a rugged weather-beaten majestically
bearded giant man who towered over the
19th century equally vast were his
achievements the father of free verse
women ditched the stultify literary
rules of his time helping forge a new
kind of poetry a uniquely american style
born of the wide vistas and rough
working men's bars of his homeland flash
forward to today and whitman's work
remains a keystone of literature
embodied in his masterpiece leaves of
grass yet how much do most of us know
about the man behind it all born on long
island in 1819 women's life was a
microcosm of 19th century america over
his seven decades and spare change he
met lincoln fought for abolition and
women's rights and witnessed firsthand
the destructive horrors of the civil war
more than just a man this is the life of
all whitman america's poet
today the name long island conjures
images of staggering wealth and new york
style density of the hamptons and george
costanza suffering shrinkage
i was in the pool but not so 200 years
ago when war whitman was born in west
hills on may 31 1819 long island was
about as rural as you could get the
second of eight surviving children from
parents of dutch and english stock
walt's earliest years were spent on the
remnants of a large tract of land his
family had once owned before being
forced to sell it off when they fell on
hard times not the poverty made the
bitter towards their homeland the
women's were almost absurdly patriotic
naming walt's brothers things like
george washington whitman and andrew
jackson whitman it was from his parents
that what would get his love of america
and his democracy the love that would be
a seem his poems return to again and
again although as we'll soon see that
love would grow to be more complex over
time especially concerning the great
issue of the day
slavery still that's all in the future
but now let's simply follow the
whitman's as they uproot and move to
brooklyn as dads move into real estate
speculation fails and he turns to
alcohol leaving the family on the brink
of poverty as walt is pulled out of
school age 11 and sent to work to make
ends meet eventually becoming an
apprentice in the printing business yeah
while he may prefer to stay in school
his family's tough circumstances didn't
put much of a dent in whitman's optimism
as he once admitted to his outlook i
stand for the sunny point of view it was
a point of view that was about to get
seriously challenged in 1835 a great
fire swept through new york city
flattening 17 blocks and destroying
hundreds of buildings among them many of
the city's printing shops suddenly out
of work in an era in which social safety
net was code for
let's kick this hobo in the nuts the 17
year old whitman turned to the only
replacement job he could find working on
long island as a teacher it was one of
the most miserable periods of his life
teaching in those days generally meant
tramping around a series of rough
one-room schools doing a term with some
rowdy kids and then moving on and while
whitman may have been an optimist any
parent will tell you that even the
sunniest disposition will eventually
crack in the face of determinist
behavior by 1840 the young man was
writing to a friend from a school room
in woodbury decrying the old school room
dirty-faced urchins and moth eaten desk
and declaring oh damn nation damnation
thy other name is school teaching and
thy residence would bree it probably
didn't help that as the job got worse
whitman was getting more and more
negligent in his duties back in 1838
he'd started his own weekly newspaper to
escape the mind-numbing horror of work
and now he spent more time ignoring his
pupils and writing than he actually did
teaching but while this may have sucked
for education standards in long island
it did wonders for whitman by 1841 he
was able to quit his job and move back
to brooklyn to work as a journalist at
which point it became clear that he was
by now effectively unemployable although
he was growing into a solid prose writer
whitman was also growing into a man with
a whole bunch of opinions opinions he
wasn't afraid to share in the most acid
ways even
when the people on the receiving end of
that acid were his employers the result
was a decade which whitman was hired and
fired by scores of newspapers for
aggressively pushing various causes from
women's rights to his hardcore belief in
unrestricted immigration but perhaps no
other issue sparked his wrath as much as
slavery a free soiler whitman had been
entranced by the wilmot proviso of 1846
a plan to outlaw slavery spread into
territories while in the
mexican-american war although the
proviso had been defeated its basic idea
became whitman's obsession an obsession
that took deeper route after a
three-month stint working in new orleans
and seeing slavery's horrors up close it
was an obsession that would see him
fired from at least one paper and
eventually lead him to becoming
disillusioned with journalism as a whole
and that disillusionment in turn would
soon lead to his greatest work
[Music]
after splitting from the free soul paper
that helped found women suddenly found
himself with a whole lot of time on his
hands and not very much to do he wasn't
exactly unemployed he owned a printing
shop and bookstore and he got involved
in some real estate ventures but he did
have more time to think away from the
din and noise of journalism time he
spent walking around new york and long
island or breeding in the public
libraries or falling in love with opera
time he also spent scribbling fragments
in a notebook fragments that would
eventually become experiments which
would in turn eventually become a whole
new style not that anyone knows exactly
when this happened for a guy so
incredibly famous there sure is a lot we
don't know about women including when he
started writing at such a high level as
a journalist his prose had been
impressive but not spectacular his
poetry in those days had likewise ranged
from ok to points for participation only
how he made his great stylistic leap
remains a mystery all that we know is
that sometime between 1849 and 1854
those experimental fragments turned into
12 perfectly formed pieces known
collectively as leaves of grass landing
in summer of 1855 leaves of grass has to
be one of the strangest debuts of any
great american writer running at just 90
pages the book was officially anonymous
with no author name amid the swirling
images of flowers it was also part of an
extremely limited print run unable to
find a publisher women had
self-published even setting the type
himself running out of money after just
795 copies what was inside though
was groundbreaking accompanied by an
image of women himself with cocked hat
and well-trimmed beard the twelve poems
swept away conventions running free and
unhindered across the page although
unnamed in this first edition poems like
icing the body electric and song of
myself were there in all their raw power
optimistic adventurous wondering poems
of america itself not that 1855 dudes
were paying much attention the first
edition of leaves of grass landed with
all the impact of a leaf falling in the
forest with no one around to hear it
although whitman tried to drum up
publicity by writing anonymous reviews
in local papers that basically when this
book is absolutely banging five out of
five neither the public nor critics seem
to notice with one important exception
that summer the great writer ralph waldo
emerson received a free copy that women
had mailed him he read it and he freaked
out writing back he declared to whitman
i greet you at the beginning of a great
career before going on to call the book
the most extraordinary piece of wit and
wisdom that america has yet contributed
to which whitman responded with
ka-ching the 1856 edition of leaves
could almost be called the shameless
cash in addition opening with emerson's
letter which whitman never got
permission to use it also used his
quotes on the spine and basically
advertised the crap out of its
connection with the more famous man
remarkably it also contained an
additional 20 new poems including the
perpetual favorite later renamed
crossing brooklyn ferry but while other
writers like henry david thoreau would
be bowled over by this edition the
public still wasn't buying and that was
a serious problem because whitman was by
now broke when thoreau went to visit
whitman he found the poet living in the
family home in brooklyn now marked by
squalor and misery like their father
before them two of whitman's brothers
were alcoholics while his sister was
suffering poor mental health so far was
the family that whitman himself was
sharing a bed with a brother clearly no
amount of friendly endorsements from
famous poets could make up for having an
actual income hence whitman's brief
return to journalism in 1857 brief
because within two years have been fired
again this time over an article
supporting women's sexual freedom broke
once more he tried to find a serious
publisher for his third edition of
leaves remarkably he actually succeeded
landing in december 1860 the third
edition is where whitman's poems hit
their scandalous peak with a section
called children of adam that openly
celebrated heterosexual love and another
calamus that seemed to allude to
romantic love between men it was also
the addition that seemed bound for
success the one that would finally make
a splash with the public only things
didn't quite work out rather than
starting 1861 as a newly successful poet
women was destined to start 1861 just
like everybody else in america as
someone whose life was about to get
flipped upside down
by the arrival of war
for the first two years of the civil war
what women's life is something of a
blank an empty room he seems to have
wandered into and disappeared we know
his publisher went bust early on taking
his hopes for leaves his third edition
down with it but it's not until december
1862 that the record becomes clearer
that's because 16th of december 1862 is
the day whitman opened the new york
herald and felt his life implode the day
before the battle of fredericksburg had
ended with one of the union's highest
casualty counts of the entire civil war
12 653 missing dead or wounded and now
hear walt whitman was staring at the
casualty list the list of names carrying
that of his brother george it's hard to
imagine what whitman was thinking as he
hurried to the dc area as he went from
hospital to hospital 40 in all each
packed with the wounded and dying it's
easy to imagine the relief when he
finally found george alive and well and
only lightly wounded but the experience
of getting so close to the war of seeing
its victims seems to have changed
something in women after accompanying a
small group of wounded soldiers back
from fredericksburg to the capitol
whitman made a profound decision he
decided to stay in early 1863 the 43
year old began the volunteering work
that would take up the next two years of
his life working in the military
hospitals providing conversation and
companionship to the wounded not being a
trained nurse his role was limited but
still on a good day women felt like he
was giving the injured men something to
cling to perhaps a reason to hold on
through the pain just a bit longer and
he really committed to it supporting
himself with part-time work in the
paymaster's office whitman used his
meager salary to buy small gifts for the
soldiers bringing them something nearly
every day today it's estimated that he
made around 600 trips offering tens of
thousands of men union and confederate
alike small morsels of comfort in return
his muse rewarded him with his greatest
work in years drum traps is a
mesmerizing poetic account of the civil
war from the early joy of fighting for a
just cause to the inescapable melancholy
of what combat really means the hurt the
blood the uncertain recovery aroused and
angry i'd thought to beat the alarm to
urge relentless war goes one verse but
soon my fingers failed me my face
drooped and i resigned myself to sit by
the wounded and sue them or silently
watch the dead it was exactly the return
to form that whitman needed capturing
what the civil war had been to so many
people who lived it yet in the end drum
taps would be overshadowed by a sequel
one written in light of horrific events
on april 15 1865 whitman was proofing
drum tabs when a man stepped into the
president's box at ford's theater and
shot abraham lincoln through the head
during his time volunteering in dc
hospitals women had become acquainted
with lincoln who'd read and enjoyed
leaves of grass and the two occasionally
dipped hats in the street so when news
reached the poet of the president's
death women did the only thing he could
do
he wrote about it wrote to give the dead
man an allergy wrote to express
everything the grieving nation was
feeling collected in the sequel to drum
taps later that same year the four poems
whitman wrote on lincoln's death remain
some of his best and best known work
from the painful epic of when lilac's
last in the door yard bloomed to the
short mournful o captain my captain the
poems for the first time brought whitman
to wide attention sadly though they did
so with the perverse logic of a cursed
monkey's poor the president women had
looked up to one had called the great
martyr chief was gone just as hundreds
of thousands of young men were victims
of the war while the coming years would
bring whitman fame they'd also bring a
hint of something alien to this most
optimistic of men a sense of creeping
disappointment in the world around him
[Music]
one of the best things to happen to
whitman in this period of national
mourning was getting on the wrong side
of james harlan the secretary of the
interior harlan was in charge of
downsizing the government but he was
also something of a massive crude a
prude who'd read leaves of grass
presumably terrified at the stirring
feeling he felt in his pants and was now
determined that whitman was to be
expelled from washington the firing of
whitman from his government post was the
exact sort of boost that his career
needed outraged at what they saw as
government censorship but byron sprang
to his defense within 24 hours had
gotten a new job at the attorney
general's office on top of that william
douglas o'connor then published a
pamphlet denouncing harlan as a censor
and portraying whitman as a modern
christ who gave his life to protect the
first amendment as a result a woman
became almost a household name when the
fourth edition of leaves dropped in 1867
it recorded decent sales for the first
time however this version of leaves
didn't just feature the newest poems
including drum taps it also chopped out
a handful from the third edition a
handful of poems that were among the
most scandalous poems that seem to
explicitly deal with romantic sexual
love between men now before we start
down this path we need to be clear that
we have no direct proof that whitman was
what we'd now call gay or queer terms
that didn't exist in his time on the
other hand we have so much
circumstantial and indirect evidence
that it quickly piles up into a fabulous
mountain that's nearly impossible to
deny first there are the live oak poems
that featured in the third edition of
leaves only to be later removed and go
without republication for a hundred
years part of the calamus set written
while whitman was living with a
strapping young irish lad named fred
vaughn the live oak poems are generally
thought to be about a relationship
between the two poem five for example is
a long declaration that whitman will
stop writing about america because he
has no time now that i have found him
who loves me as i him in
perfect love and also includes the lines
i am indifferent to my own songs i am to
go with him i love and he is to go with
me it is to be enough for each of us
that we are together we never separate
again meanwhile pern 8 is thought to be
written after they broke up with a
section that reads hours discouraged
distracted for he the one i cannot
content myself without soon i saw him
content himself without me remember this
is on top of the non-removed poems in
calamus that still refer to sexy dude on
dude love albeit in a slightly less
direct way there are other hints too
such as the letters whitman wrote about
some of the soldiers he tended to while
volunteering in dc describing their
splendid necks frames and clean
complexions and strong bodies but
perhaps the strongest argument for
whitman's same-sex attraction is peter
doyle another young irishman doyle had
fought for the confederacy surviving the
war to become a train car conductor he
met whitman while working and the two
more or less immediately began a
decade-long relationship that many
consider to have been romantic in nature
certainly whitman was fond of referring
to doyle as my darling or my darling boy
in his letters and the two spent long
periods in the 1860s and 1870s
cohabiting with doyle even acting as
whitman's carer when his health
collapsed today it's assumed that doyle
was whitman's lover probably even the
greatest love of his life but with
same-sex attraction being so taboo in
those days it's impossible to say for
sure they simply left no hard evidence
no diaries no signed confession that
reads dear future scholars oh we were
totally boning so all we can do is try
to read between the lines and see the
traces of a love story that no one in
the era would have dead right but even
if this period saw walt whitman the
lover consigned to invisibility the same
could only be said of whitman the poet
because the years he spent with doyle
would also coincide with whitman finally
becoming world famous
[Music]
as the 1860s ticked towards their end
more and more readers were beginning to
take notice of the bearded bare-chested
satire of american letters partially
this was due to the success of drum taps
and the lincoln elegies but it was also
due to a new generation of scholars
championing whitman's work 1967 saw
notes on what whitman as poet and person
reignite scholarly interest while 1868
saw the first british edition of his
poems published interestingly for a poet
as solidly american as whitman the brits
went nuts over his verse by the
mid-1870s after the publication of
leaves his fifth edition it'd be so
popular in the uk that british critics
were able to write long articles calling
americans uncultured swine for ignoring
this genius in their midst but while
whitman's star might at last have been
rising
things weren't all perfect 1873 saw the
suffer his first stroke leaving him
partially paralyzed and forced to
eventually quit his government job and
move in with his brother george come the
end of the decade he and peter doyle had
likewise drifted apart although they'd
remain in contact and are thought to
have restarted their relationship at one
point what was perhaps the greatest
romance of whitman's life was now over
yet it would be a third potential
catastrophe that wound up sealing
whitman's reputation all right so
remember possible james harlan getting
so worked up about whitman's immoral
poetry well apparently he wasn't the
only one to get his knickers in a twist
over the more risque parts of leaves in
1882 just as the sixth edition was about
to go on sale the boston district
attorney announced that he was banning
the book he even tried to ban the act of
sending it bar mail if you ever read
whitman's poems in school you might be
wondering what the fuss was about this
wasn't exactly naked lunch but this is
the past of course they do things
differently there so women was forced to
find a new publisher outside of boston
all the while the press talked up this
immoral book until everyone on earth had
heard of the controversy the result
inevitably was to make the sixth edition
a smash hit for the first time in his
life whitman made enough money to buy
himself a little house in camden new
jersey there he settled into the final
act of his life as a famous poet at last
able to rest on his laurels these were
the twilight years the years in which
people like the irish poet oscar wilde
made pilgrimages across the atlantic to
meet the great writer the years in which
he was at last able to bask in the glow
of recognition yet even now there was
still a dark cloud forever threatening
to obscure whitman's sunny optimism as
the 1880s creaked into the 1890s women
became disenchanted with america's
direction with the land that had
rhapsodized as a young man a place he
came to believe had taken too many wrong
turns after the civil war after it lost
its greatest captain not the whitman
would live to see the rest of the
journey after a long winter of illness
what whitman died on march 26 1892 at
the age of 72. by this point it was so
famous that papers like the new york
times kept a bedside vigil updating
their readers each day on the dying
man's prognosis when the time came for
the final update it was like the curtain
had just fallen over an entire era but
the moment he died women left behind one
of the most remarkable poetic legacies
of all time over six official editions
and three reissues leaves of grass had
come to encompass nearly 300 poems each
a testament to a wholly new way of
writing of seeing the world so perfect
were they that rather than fade he only
grew in fame after his death until in
the here and now his name stands at the
pinnacle of american poetry up there
with edgar allan poe robert frost or
emily dickinson and maybe perhaps above
them all it's pleasing in a way that a
man so defiantly outside the
establishment a political street fighter
who wrote in vernacular and likely took
male lovers would wind up becoming the
most established poets the one everyone
has to learn about in school and make no
mistake he deserves to be there what
women may not have quite invented free
verse but he arguably invented something
even greater a form of poetry of seeing
the world that was unique to his beloved
homeland
[Music]
you